واو يا إلهي أن صورتك هي أنا
لا تبدو مثلك عندما كنت
أصغر سنًا ، هذا وجهي صورة
لم أرها منذ سنوات تم العثور عليها في ثوانٍ من
خلال تطبيق التعرف على الوجه الذي تم
عرضه بوضوح ، لذا فإن صورتنا الجديدة
أيقظنا تحقيق يورك تايمز جميعًا أن
إدراك الخصوصية قد يكون شيئًا
من الماضي وهذا بسبب هذا الرجل
الذي ابتكر تقنية Clearview AI التي ابتكرها Tosh ،
وببساطة ، فإن الرؤية الواضحة هي في
الأساس محرك بحث عن الوجوه
فكر في الصور التي تريدها.  لقد نشرنا
على الإنترنت أو صورًا نشرها الآخرون
لك ، فهناك فرصة جيدة لأن يقوم
بجمعها ، قام تطبيقه بإزالة
مليارات الصور من مواقع مثل
Facebook Twitter و Google لاستخدام
نظام التعرف على الوجه الذي يدعي أنه أكثر
من 600 وكالة إنفاذ القانون في
الولايات المتحدة  وكندا تستخدمه على الرغم من أنه من
غير الواضح عدد الأشخاص الذين دفعوا بالفعل مقابل
ذلك ، فصوروني من موقع cnn.com ، فنحن على يقين من
رؤية صور لي ليست من
تلك الصورة الأصلية ، هذه من
عمالقة التكنولوجيا المتوسطة  لست سعيدًا بهذا
الأمر ، يقولون إنه ينتهك شروط
الخدمة الخاصة بهم وقد أرسلت رسائل توقف وكف على
LinkedIn Twitter YouTube ، لذا
هذه الصورة من صحيفتي المحلية ،
تبحث تقنية الذكاء الاصطناعي هذه
في ما تبحث عنه في الميزات الفريدة
لذلك تتعلم  لتجاهل أشياء
مثل اللحية قليلاً والتركيز على
الميزات التي تظل كما هي عبر أي
عمر مختلف ، هل تفهم
الأشخاص البيض الذين يجدون هذا مخيفًا يمكنني
فهم الأشخاص الذين لديهم مخاوف بشأن
الخصوصية ، لذا فإن الجزء الأول
هو تذكر المعلومات المتاحة للجمهور فقط
نحن لا نصنع التكنولوجيا
لمصلحتها فقط ، والسبب والغرض الذي
اكتشفناه هو مساعدة تطبيق القانون حقًا على
حل الجريمة ،
لقد كنت منزعجة للغاية ، كنت قلقًا
بشأن الطريقة التي جمعت بها Clearview
قاعدة بياناتها للصور كنت قلقًا بشأن
خصوصية بياناتها و  كنت قلقًا من
أنه كان يتتبع
عمليات البحث عن إنفاذ القانون بالقرب من العرض الذي يزعم بوضوح
أنه يعمل ، أعني أنهم قالوا هنا في
نيوجيرسي من كنا  لتحديد
طفل مفترس مشتبه به في العام الماضي في
هذه العمليات اللاذعة التي نقوم بها
لدينا محقق مدرب على الإنترنت
يتظاهر بأنه فريق أو عامل منجم ، لذلك نحن
نعلم أن الشخص قد ارتكب
جريمة ونحن نعلم أنهم قادمون
الموقع السري حيث ستعتقلهم جهات
إنفاذ القانون ما
لا نعرفه هو من هو هذا الشخص ولكن
ما لدينا هو صورة
أرسلوها إلى المتخفي ولذا
تم استخدام تطبيق Clearview للحصول على
اسم الفرد  عند القدوم إلى
الموقع السري ، نريدها أن
تكتشف ما الذي يمتلكه هذا الشخص من أسلحة نارية ،
هل لديه تطوعي ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي
تم بها استخدام هذه الأداة في هذه الحالة بالذات ،
ولم يتم استخدامها لتطوير السبب المحتمل
لاعتقال هذا الشخص الذي تم استخدامه من
أجله  أغراض سلامة إنفاذ القانون ،
هل أنت قلق بشأن إخراج أداة
قوية مثل تلك من أيدي سلطات إنفاذ القانون
، فأنا لا أعارض بشكل قاطع استخدام
تقنية التعرف على
الوجه كأداة للتعرف على الوجه  يمكن استخدامها
بشكل صحيح إذا فهمنا كيفية
إنشاء قاعدة البيانات سواء كانت أداة
التعرف على الوجه أداة فعالة جدًا
للتحقيق الجنائي أم لا ، يمكننا
التفكير في أن هذا السؤال بعيد قليلاً
عن النقطة السؤال هو ما
الذي نريد أن تكون الشرطة قادرة عليه  تعرف
علينا نظرًا لأن معظمنا لم
يفعل حقًا أي شيء يضمن وجود
معلوماتنا في قواعد بيانات إنفاذ القانون ،
لذا سأطلب من المنتج
ريشا أن يدير وجهها من خلال هذا ،
حسنًا ، هل لديك وسائط أنا موجود هناك
؟  لم يفشل أي عرض توضيحي مطلقًا حتى الآن ، انتظر
هذا Instagram أنا خاص على
Instagram ، هذا هو Instagram الخاص بشخص آخر ،
لذا نعم متاح للجمهور فقط
هذا انتظر ولكن هذا ملكي أيضًا ، كنت
علنيًا في وقت ما ، ثم أصبحت
خاصًا حتى تعرف ذلك إذا كنت  انطلق إلى
العلن وهذا هو Instagram الخاص بي أيضًا
وأنا خاص الآن ، لكنني كنت عامًا في
وقت ما إذا كانت الصورة متاحة للجمهور ، فإن
تقنية العروض الواضحة قادرة على
التقاطها ، لا يهم إذا قمت
بحذفها لاحقًا أو  r تغيير إعدادات الخصوصية
، لا يهم حتى إذا قام
شخص ما بنشر الرماد بدون
علمك أو إذنك ، والدي ليس
لديه حساب على Facebook ولكني قمت بوضع
صور لأبي على الإنترنت ، فهذا رأيك هو
أنه بموافقته على الحصول على صورة
لقد أخذ
أنه وافق عن غير قصد على التواجد
في قاعدة البيانات الخاصة بك ، هل قمت
بنشرها علنًا ، هل قلت لا ربما
لا
ولكنك تعلم ، هذا هو مدى روعة هذا الأمر
، وهناك أيضًا وجهة نظرنا التي تعلمنا
أنها تستخدم لحالة الاستخدام هذه ، قل ليس والدك
ولكن شخصًا ما  آخر كان في
خلفية تلك الصورة وقد يؤدي ذلك إلى
حل جريمة
تدعي Clearview أن تطبيقها دقيق بنسبة 99 ٪ ،
وهي مطالبة بأن CNN لم تتحقق مما إذا
كانت تحدد الشخص الخطأ وهذا
يؤدي إلى إدانة خاطئة هل أنت
قلق بشأن  نعم ، لا نريد
أن يحدث ذلك على الإطلاق ولهذا
السبب الطريقة المستخدمة حاليًا في جميع
وكالات إنفاذ القانون من حولنا
هو التأكد من أنه مجرد خيط
لم أتحدث إليه مع أي من
وكالات إنفاذ القانون الذين يعتقدون أنه
يجب استخدام معرفات التعرف على الوجه
كدليل في المحكمة ، فهم يستخدمونها فقط
كأداة تحقيق والتي أعتقد
أنها تخفف قليلاً أيضًا  من
مخاوف المجتمع ، نحتاج إلى
وضع إرشادات لموظفي إنفاذ
القانون المصرح لهم باستخدام هذا - هل
تم تدريبهم على ذلك ، وبعد ذلك عندما
يحصلون على هذه النتائج ، يتم تدريبهم
عندئذٍ ليعرفوا أنها مجرد حشيش ، لذلك
تعتقد أن هذه منطقة  يجب أن يتم
تنظيم ذلك ، نعم بالتأكيد
لا أعتقد أن التنظيم أمر سيئ
ونريد العمل مع الحكومة
لإنشاء شيء آمن ،
هل قابلت أي مشرع نعم
نعم لقد عقدنا اجتماعات حتى الآن إذا
اجتمعت قبل فترة  التقينا ببعض
الأشخاص وسنعقد المزيد من الاجتماعات
ولم تقم بتسمية أي منهم.
ممتاز في هذا المجال ، نعم ، أعتقد
أنه سيكون هناك الكثير من الأيام
بالطبع ، هل أنت مستعد لذلك بالتأكيد
، لا أعتقد أنهم سيكونون بهذا العدد
ولكنك تعرفك